the architecture advaithic roof is
spectacular and modern the cultivation
methods are more traditional we are by
Namek form and we see the whole form as
a living entity which means not just the
vineyard but the fine boss also and you
want that natural flow of positive
energy right through the form and having
your natural vegetation and your natural
fauna and flora and the energy enhanced
in your vineyards in your wines in the
whole process is very special and it
makes this form one living entity
vertically fizz a wine estate on the
Cape renowned for its commitment to
sustainable farming and winemaking farm
manager Christian Lutz also uses manure
to enrich the soil with microorganisms
and to keep pests in check chemicals are
not part of his repertoire this form
hasn't used any pesticides or herbicides
since 2008 everything that we use comes
from the form we use the type of
fungicides we used a spirit of fungi
things you find in your compost heap
Christian Lutz has a visitor
Joan ischium from the World Wildlife
Fund in 2008 it declared vertically a
conservation champion the distinction is
only awarded to vineyards that fulfilled
rigorous environmental criteria all our
conservation champions there's about
thirty seven of them they all get a
formal review every year and that's when
I come out to the farms and just want to
actually monitor how are they doing with
the environmental management that would
include the alien clearing the fire
management we're also looking at waste
management problem animal control
anything to do with environmental risks
on the form varta Kluth is one of 600
vineyards in the Cape Winelands here the
grapes all picked and processed by hand
the estate makes up to two hundred and
forty thousand liters of wine a year for
the domestic market and for export
christian lourdes takes joan ischium on
a tour of inspection more than half the
146 hectare estate has been set aside as
a conservation area instead of vines
endemic bushes and shrubs flourished
there the fan boss is the natural
heathland of the Western Cape it forms
part of the Cape floral Kingdom a region
with an incredible number of plant
species
what's more two-thirds of the 9,000
species are only found on the Cape but
that's not all it might happen that one
specie only occur on one specific form
nowhere else even in the Western Cape so
if it's lost there and we don't motivate
me to look after that specie it will be
lost for the world the greatest threats
to the Cape floral Kingdom are invasive
alien plant species urbanization and
farming ischium says it's very important
to get more wine growers onboard to
become conservation champions
conservation brings them a range of
advantages we do find boss walks and we
do wine tasting on horseback through the
fine boss then they are the biological
aspect of it let's operators bleed in
the fine boss and available to the vines
in spring so they actually migrate from
the fine boss into the vineyards to
control our pace ischium concludes that
Environmental Management at vertically
is good you don't see a lien vegetation
the island vegetative there in the
distance they will still deal with
that's a future plan so we've recognised
their conservation efforts by allowing
them to use the little sugar bird Protea
logo on their wine bottle lutes is
passionate about biodynamic farming he
goes way beyond the WWF's criteria for
being a conservation champion here
natural process
as do the jobs many farmers assigned to
machines and chemicals sheep graze in
the vineyards reducing the level of
weeds between the rows of vines a
sustainable form like this will be
around in the next hundred years the
vines will grow up to 50 years old my
son and and so on will still be able to
form this soil because the soil is alive
its living Joan ischium hopes to sign up
ten more states as conservation
champions by the end of the year to help
ensure a future for both wine growing
and the fame boss